i have a very contrasting
set of comments from the other candidate
to play for you
joe biden came out last night before
donald trump around 1am roughly in the
morning east coast time
and he was notable in that he behaved
like a normal person
we didn't know at the time and we still
don't know now
who is the winner of the race and joe
biden
doesn't come out like trump and say i
won
joe biden doesn't come out and say i won
states that haven't actually been called
which
uh donald trump did joe biden comes out
and makes it clear
we knew it would take a while and we
believe we still have a path to winning
which is true he may not win
but as i showed you earlier earlier in
exquisite detail he does have a path
here's joe biden
your patience is commendable we knew
this was gonna go wrong
but who knew we're gonna go into maybe
tomorrow morning maybe even longer
but look we feel good about where we are
we really do
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
so of course joe biden is optimistic as
any campaign would be until it's clear
you're not going to win
but unlike donald trump joe biden is
being a responsible adult
joe biden is not declaring a victory
that he doesn't have joe biden is not
declaring victories in states
that have not been called and which in
fact as donald trump said were winning
wisconsin and michigan
those states flipped to joseph r biden
jr
notice that joe biden doesn't claim a
victory absent an actual victory to
claim
he doesn't allege fraud absent actual
fraud to claim he doesn't say he will go
to court
to try to stop ballots from being
counted
the contrast is stunning and the fact
that so many americans don't care is a
problem which i am going to get to a
little bit later
increasingly joe biden's path depends on
pennsylvania although as i said earlier
even without it
biden can win with nevada
michigan and wisconsin but joe biden
says they feel good about pennsylvania
this was last night we still have to see
how the numbers come in
but we're feeling good we're feeling
good about where we are
we believe one of the nets has suggested
we've already won
arizona but we're confident about
arizona that's a turnaround
we also just called it from minnesota
and we're still in the game in georgia
although
that's not what we expected
[Applause]
and we're feeling real good about
wisconsin and michigan
[Applause]
and by the way it's going to take time
to count the votes we're going to win
pennsylvania
and as we will uh continue to see
pennsylvania if it were to flip back to
biden
as that remaining 35-ish percent of the
vote is counted
it could be a huge part of biden's path
to victory if indeed he gets it
it would be the ultimate red mirage
scenario major major factor
and then lastly here is joe biden saying
we could know the results as early as
tomorrow morning
but it is not up to him to say when it
is final
it is up to the american people and of
course the people actually counting the
ballots take a look at this
look you know we could know the results
as early as tomorrow morning but it may
take a little longer as i've said all
along
it's not my place or donald trump's
place to declare who's won this election
that's the decision of the american
people but i'm optimistic about this
outcome
[Music]
i want to thank every one of you who
came out
and voted in this election and by the
way chris coons and the democrats
congratulations here in delaware so
the contrast continue if you thought the
the the wackiness would stop on election
day you were very wrong
joe biden acting like a normal person
connected to reality not a delusional
narcissist it's nice for a change donald
trump coming out in a rally-like
atmosphere
claiming he won claiming he won states
in which
leads were evaporating literally as he
spoke
claiming fraud and claiming he will go
to the supreme court
it's incredible guys it's incred we need
to maintain our democratic systems
and donald trump is taking a
sledgehammer
or a chef's knife or whatever a sword
anything donald trump could pick up with
those hands of his
um and we need to protect democracy
we'll continue covering this
on instagram where you can find us at
david pakman davidpakmanshow
follow me on instagram david.pakman
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully
there's a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video